[Aplausos]
[Música]
ucrania es el paris hilton de los países
cada vez que se habla de ellas en los
medios suele ser porque ha ocurrido algo
malo cuando pensamos en ucrania pensamos
en chernóbil la guerra con rusia o el
escándalo de corrupción que llegó a
trump a su primer proceso de impeachment
[Música]
lo cierto es que la historia de ucrania
es para echarse a llorar en serio si
algún día os echan del trabajo os deja
vuestra pareja os pasa cualquier
desgracia legend algo sobre historia de
ucrania o ve de este vídeo porque seguro
que os hace sentirnos mejor hablamos del
país más pobre de toda europa en
términos de peine per cápita los
ucranianos son tan pobres como los
salvadoreños o los turcomanos sin
embargo todo esto puede cambiar y
estamos a punto de ver el momento de la
verdad en estos meses el presidente de
ucrania volodymyr selenski tiene el gran
dilema del que depende todo el futuro de
su país a qué me estoy refiriendo pues
al final de este vídeo lo vais a
entender todo responderemos a esta
pregunta pero antes porque ucrania es
tan pobre
[Música]
porque alguno dirá que está muy claro
ucrania perteneció a la unión soviética
tuvieron un pasado comunista y ahora son
pobres sin embargo hay muchos otros
países que también formaron parte de la
órbita soviética y que ahora son
democracias prósperas y con buena
calidad de vida y hasta el caso de
polonia república checa estonia todos
estos países son hoy naciones prósperas
con unos niveles de vida equiparables a
cualquier país europeo y curiosamente
ahora polonia y chequia están llenos de
ucranianos ucranianos que vienen unos
meses a trabajar en la construcción por
ejemplo para volverse después a su país
[Música]
de hecho según algunas estimaciones el
12% del pib de ucrania viene de las
remesas de dinero que les llegan del
extranjero se estima que más de 10
millones de ucranianos trabajan en el
extranjero aunque sólo sea durante unos
pocos meses al año y digo se estima
porque la mayor parte de la economía
ucraniana es informal pensad que ahora
mismo hablamos de un país que está en un
conflicto prácticamente permanente con
rusia pero no esa no es la única razón
por la que son tan pobres así que la
pregunta que nos hacemos es porque
ucrania es tan pobre que y andrés pasa
en este país para que en 30 años de
haber abandonado el comunismo estén peor
incluso que cuando eran parte de la
unión soviética hoy vamos a responder a
esta pregunta pero antes antes vamos a
hablar de internet word que si los
ucranianos lo saben muy bien porque ya
están acostumbrados a lidiar con hackers
de todo el mundo y qué es lo que hacen
cómo se protegen de un ciberataque o es
exacto utilizando una vpn una vpn como
sur sac vpn
[Música]
surfers que es una vpn fantástica porque
no solo nos protege de hackers de bots
de propaganda rusa y de virus chungos
que encontramos por ahí además permite
que podamos entrar en cualquier sitio de
internet sin encontrarnos con esos
mensajes de esta página está bloqueado
en tu país vamos que puedes entrar en
cualquier sitio web de forma segura
además cursar tiene una herramienta que
se llama link web que bloquea todos esos
popups de propaganda por donde se cuelan
todos esos bots y cookies que
francamente no queremos tener en nuestro
ordenador
[Música]
por si todo esto fuera poco con una
misma cuenta de surf shark podrás
registrar todos los dispositivos que
quieras que quieres navegar con
seguridad desde tu smart tv o desde tu
teléfono móvil o desde tu ordenador pues
todo eso lo puedes hacer con la misma
cuenta de surf shark y por supuesto
tenemos un descuento de lujo para todos
vosotros que seguir mis políticas
básicamente si utilizáis el código
político terminado en cada visual
político tendréis un 83% de descuento
más tres meses extra totalmente
gratuitos os dejo los enlaces en la
descripción no esperéis más y
descargaros ya la aplicación y ahora sí
vamos a ver un poco de historia
[Música]
el capitalismo que nunca fue os voy a
hacer una pregunta habéis oído hablar
alguna vez del avión antonov an225 se
trata del avión más grande del mundo por
cierto que si queréis conocer hasta el
último detalle hasta el último tornillo
de este coloso de los aires podéis
visitar el vídeo que hicimos en nuestro
canal hermano en megaproyectos con cut
de visual político pues bien este
prodigio de la técnica está hecho
íntegramente en ucrania si mis queridos
amigos de visual polític ucrania es uno
de los nueve países del mundo donde
puedes fabricar aviones sin tener que
salir del país tienen toda la cadena de
producción aeroespacial dentro de sus
propias fronteras y esto es algo de lo
que muy pocos países pueden presumir
[Música]
pero todo esto ucrania es tan pobre como
türkmenistán o el salvador donde ya os
digo que no se pueden fabricar aviones
si todavía no estáis intrigados os doy
otro dato ucrania tiene recursos
naturales de todo tipo hierro uranio y
toda clase de metales además tienen uno
de los terrenos más fértiles para la
agricultura
el llamado ser no cm o tierra negra es
un tipo de tierra que por lo visto es
fantástico para cultivar de hecho
durante décadas
ucrania era el granero de la unión
soviética pese a todo esto este país ha
sufrido una invasión ágil y una
soviética hecho durante la época de
stalin la población fue sometida a una
de las hambrunas más terribles de la
historia
el llamado holodomor y tras la calidad
del comunismo
ucrania era una de las repúblicas más
pobres de toda la órbita soviética
un país que además estaba dividido en
dos grandes grupos los que hablan ruso
que están en las regiones del este y los
que hablan ucraniano que están en el
oeste como os podéis imaginar estas
divisiones van mucho más allá del idioma
básicamente la población ucraniano
parlante quiere y ucrania pase a ser una
economía de mercado que comercio con
europa y la población rusa parlante
quiere mantener una economía más o menos
centralizada y mantener los lazos
comerciales con rusia todo esto explica
que ucrania nunca haya tenido una
transición real hacia el capitalismo
prueba de ello es que a día de hoy
todavía tienen más de 3600 empresas
estatales y toda esta transición no
completa hacia el capitalismo la podemos
ver curiosamente en como privatizaron la
parte de economía que si llegaron a
poner en manos privadas
[Música]
pensando de esta manera el comunismo
soviético se basa en una economía
gestionada por el estado es decir que
todas las empresas son estatales desde
las grandes energéticas hasta la última
fábrica de chocolatinas
por eso el paso más importante en una
transición de comunismo al capitalismo
pasa por privatizar casi todas esas
empresas por eso tanto ucrania como
polonia estonia república checa o casi
todos los países excomunistas tuvieran
sus procesos de privatizaciones a
principios de los años 90 sin embargo
como siempre decimos en visual política
el [ __ ] está en los detalles para que
lo entendamos mejor vamos a comparar las
privatizaciones en república checa con
las de ucrania
si estáis suscritos a este canal desde
hace tiempo ya conoceréis la historia
porque os la hemos contado un montón de
veces y si no estáis suscritos a visual
política pues no sé a qué esperáis
suscribiros ya gigante a la campanita
para no perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones pero volvamos con
nuestra historia
[Música]
veréis tras el fin del comunismo el
gobierno checo calculó el valor de todas
sus empresas y lo dividió en vales vales
que vendió a los ciudadanos a un precio
moderado de hecho el 80% de los
ciudadanos checos compró algunos de
estos vales que más tarde se podrían
canjear por acciones de la empresa es
decir que en el momento en el que el
gobierno subastará la empresa es decir
la privatizar a tú podrías hacerte con
acciones de la empresa muy fácilmente y
por eso a día de hoy casi todos los
ciudadanos checos tienen acciones en
empresas nacionales todo esto explica en
parte por qué república checa- es uno de
los países más igualitarios del mundo y
atentos porque esto muy poca gente lo
sabe pero chequia es uno de los países
con menos diferencias entre ricos y
pobres del mundo superan incluso a los
países nórdicos
[Música]
el caso de ucrania no podía ser más
distinto sí es cierto aquí también el
estado se dedicó a vender vales de sus
empresas a los ciudadanos pero aquí
viene la diferencia vamos a imaginar que
somos un ciudadano ucraniano en los años
90 que trabaja en esa fábrica de
chocolatinas de la que hablábamos antes
el estado nos dice que va a privatizar
la empresa y que por el equivalente a
1500 dólares podemos comprar una
participación cuando su parte de la
empresa podremos canjear nuestro
papelito por un paquete de acciones
hasta aquí todo normal el problema el
problema es que este papelito este vale
no vale nada nunca mejor dicho hasta que
no subasta en la empresa y lo podamos
canjear por acciones reales y resulta
que ese momento nunca llega pensadlo
bien las élites que gobernaban la nueva
e independiente ucrania eran las mismas
que habían estado en el poder durante la
unión soviética sólo cambiaron el nombre
del partido que de llamarse partido
comunista pasaron a llamarse partido
socialdemócrata por lo demás mismas
caras mismas ideas y mismos intereses
conclusión pues que tú habías comprado
un vale que nos servía
y en ese momento es cuando llega un
señor que vamos a poner que se llama
petro porro seca quedamos con este
nombre porque va a ser importante más
adelante pues bien el tal petro
poroshenko y tantos otros como él es un
señor que estaba muy bien conectado con
el gobierno que ha juntado un dinerillo
con amigos y familiares este buen señor
nos llega y nos dice ira chaval o
chavala este papelito que tienes no vale
nada y tú necesitas dinero así que mira
yo te doy cien dólares por él y al menos
puedes pagar el alquiler y llegar a fin
de mes que hacemos evidentemente se lo
vendemos y justo en ese momento cuando
el señor poroshenko me ha comprado el
papelito a mí y a todos mis compañeros
de trabajo sorpresa el estado llega y
subasta la fábrica de chocolates en
otras palabras que por muy poco dinero
poroshenko se ha hecho con la propiedad
de una fábrica de chocolates pues parece
injusto pues así es como nació en el año
1996 el grupo ros en que hoy en día es
el principal fabricante de dulces de
ucrania
de hecho el señor poroshenko es conocido
como el rey del chocolate pues bien por
los en ccoo es un ejemplo de oligarca
m
la idea se calcula que el 85 por ciento
de la riqueza de ucrania está en manos
de oligarcas y podríamos decir que los
oligarcas son como el sueño americano
pero versión mal son grandes empresarios
que se han hecho ricos gracias a los
favores políticos y no gracias a vender
un producto competitivo en el mercado
por ejemplo recordáis es echarnos en pan
fértil para el cultivo pues casi todas
las tierras de cultivo de ucrania están
en manos de 25 terratenientes nada más
25 personas y diréis dónde está el
problema es el mercado amigo pues lo
cierto es que no de hecho hasta hace
poco tiempo la compraventa de suelo
agrícola en ucrania estaba prohibida es
decir que los oligarcas se hicieron con
las tierras durante las privatizaciones
pero ahora las ley les protege para que
las mantengan pase lo que pase
conclusión de la agricultura ucraniana
es totalmente no competitiva e
improductiva pese a tener tierras hiper
fértiles el 70% de la tierra produce la
mitad por hectárea de lo que produce en
eeuu a todo esto tenemos que sumarle
todos los escándalos de corrupción en
las empresas estatales para que os
hagáis una idea la empresa más grande
del país es naftogas más atrás es la
empresa de gas ucraniana que pertenecía
al estado no se ha privatizado seguro en
zintan clic y es la corrupción de esta
empresa supone más de 3 mil millones de
dólares al año y obviamente toda esta
corrupción se traduce en pérdidas
millonarias
[Música]
para que os hagáis una idea solo en el
año 2014 las pérdidas de naftogas
suponían un 6% del pib ucraniano en
otras palabras
ucrania es pobre en muy buena medida por
culpa de la corrupción de los propios
ucranianos pero ya sé lo que estaréis
pensando muchos a ver fonseca no está
siendo un poco injusto ucrania está en
guerra con rusia tienen regiones enteras
invadidas por el ejército ruso de verdad
esto no tiene un impacto económico pues
sí y ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
[Música]
limpieza general a no ser que viváis en
una cueva todos sabéis que rusia y
ucrania son enemigos acérrimos esta
guerra empezó tras las protestas del
euro maidana miles de jóvenes salieron a
las calles de kiev a protestar contra el
gobierno la policía les reprimió
violentamente pero finalmente lograron
derrocar al gobierno propuso de víctor
yanukóvich
lo que seguramente no sepáis es porque
empezó todo esto pensando bien hasta el
año 2014 la mayoría de los super - no
querían entrar en la otan
por aquel entonces rusia era el
principal socio comercial del país y
grace que ocurrió para que la situación
haya dado semejante giro de 180 grados
pues todo empezó por esta noticia
[Música]
grant ya suspende las negociaciones del
tratado de libre comercio con la unión
europea y putin gana el pulso por
resumir hasta el año 2013 rusia era el
principal socio comercial de ucrania
busca ya su gas a ucrania vendía sus
metales y sus cereales sin embargo rusia
no quería depender tanto del kremlin y
así es como empezaron a negociar un
tratado de libre comercio con la unión
europea
a finales de 2013 el presidente de
ucrania estaba a punto de firmar este
tratado pero putin le presionó para que
se echara atrás recordáis que os decía
que ucrania se divide en dos mitades
pues bien la mitad ucraniano parlante
entendió que el veto a este tratado era
una traición y así es como estallaron
las protestas del euro mayrán estas
protestas sirvieron para derrocar el
gobierno de viktor yanúkovich y entonces
la mitad rusoparlante se sintió
traicionada y cuáles son las regiones
más rusoparlantes de todo el país
exacto crimea donde es ilógico
y por eso tras el éxito del euro maidán
estas regiones quisieron separarse del
resto de rusia
saldaña en su directorio de sudán
danny es que haya una rondalla numéricas
y rusia apoyo a los separatistas así es
cómo estalló la guerra de ucrania
[Música]
sin embargo de todo esto ya hablaremos
más en profundidad en otro vídeo porque
hoy nos vamos a centrar en la economía
la primera consecuencia económica de
esta guerra fue el fin del comercio con
rusia fijaos en esta caja
[Aplausos]
como podéis ver a medida que ucrania
deja de comerciar con rusia empieza a
comerciar con la unión europea a día de
hoy bruselas es el principal socio
comercial del kiel y muchos sobre todo
los que seáis muy europeístas pensarías
que todo esto suponía un nuevo comienzo
para ucrania un cambio de rumbo el fin
de la oligarquía pro rusa verdad por lo
cierto es que no a que no adivina quién
fue el siguiente presidente ucraniano
después de yanukóvich venga podéis hacer
apuestas un segundo vamos con ello
el rey del chocolate poroshenko gana la
presidencia ucraniana aunque la
violencia continúa habéis oído bien que
era en la sustituyó a la oligarquía
rusoparlante por otra oligarquía
ucraniano parlante todo cambio para que
todo siguiera igual desde entonces
ucrania ha prometido un sinfín de planes
de lucha contra la corrupción han
surgido varias plataformas de la
sociedad civil para llevar los casos más
flagrantes a los tribunales pero a la
vez las élites de kiev han intentado
frenar muchas de estas propuestas así
fue hasta el año 2019 y diréis qué pasó
en el año 2019 pues ahora mismo lo vamos
a ver
[Música]
en el momento de la verdad os acordáis
del primer impeachment contra trump si
recordáis todo empezó porque trump
supuestamente prometió unas ayudas
militares a ucrania a cambio de que
habrían una investigación contra by the
end corría el año 2019 y así es como el
mundo entero conoció al nuevo presidente
ucraniano volodymyr el ex dijo a petro
poroshenko
y habilitado un debate si pensabas que
me asustaría y me escondería y no soy
como tú en 2014 vale os voy a poner en
situación os acordáis del ajuste de la
casa blanca pues imaginad que martin
sheen después de interpretar el papel de
presidente de los eeuu se presenta como
presidente de los eeuu pero tiene perfil
real no fake es este es exactamente el
caso de volodymyr telesquí hablamos de
un actor de televisión que se hizo
famoso interpretando el papel de
presidente de ucrania en una serie en el
momento más dulce de su carrera de actor
se presentó a las elecciones pocos muy
pocos habríamos apostado por su carrera
política pero contra todo pronóstico en
mayo de 2019 gana las elecciones al
señor petro poroshenko su mensaje era yo
soy mi prorruso ni antirruso mi enemigo
es la corrupción y los oligarcas y todo
esto explica que bajo su gobierno se han
aprobado medidas como ésta
[Música]
el parlamento ucraniano aprobó una ley
para abrir el mercado del suelo agrícola
que empezará en julio de 2021 recordáis
aquellas leyes que blindaban a los
oligarcas ucranianos pues poco a poco el
gobierno cree no está cambiando las
enfermero de 2021 de hecho congelaron
las cuentas de otro oligarca pro ruso en
este caso el multimillonario víctor
netbook todas estas medidas son muy
importantes para ucrania no sólo sirven
para limpiar el país además son
esenciales para que puedan recibir ayuda
internacional por ejemplo
ucrania ha pedido un préstamo de 5 mil
millones de dólares al fondo monetario
internacional pero este préstamos eeuu
no llegarán si ucrania se toma muy en
serio su lucha contra la corrupción y
por cierto aquí tengo que hacer un
paréntesis probablemente no veréis este
tipo de noticias en un periódico normal
pero sabéis donde si podéis leer
análisis sobre este tipo de temas todas
las semanas
exacto apoyando a visual político en
patrio desde hace varios meses hemos
lanzado una newsletter titulada las
claves de la semana donde os informamos
de este tipo de temas que sí son muy
importantes pero que por alguna
se quedan fuera de los grandes titulares
es decir que no sólo estaréis apoyando a
visual política sino que además
recibiréis más información y más
análisis que difícilmente encontrareis
en otros medios de comunicación hechos
de paréntesis sigamos con la historia ya
sé lo que estaréis pensando muchos en
este momento selenski debe ser todo un
héroe para los ucranianos el hombre que
está haciendo justicia contra los
oligarcas verdad pues lo cierto es que
el esquí empezó su presidencia con unos
porcentajes enormes de popularidad pero
en el último año ha caído en picado el
más su partido se ha pegado un
cacharrazo de proporciones nada
solidarias en las últimas elecciones
municipales muchos pensaréis que todo
esto se debe al coronavirus es verdad
que son malos tiempos para gobernar
ningún país pero recordad que estamos
hablando de ucrania el país del sueño
ucraniano que es como el sueño americano
pero mal lograr el éxito en ucrania sin
contar con los oligarcas es
prácticamente imposible y
desgraciadamente si eso también incluye
hace lenski
en eeuu impone sanciones al oligarca
ucraniano igor kolomoisky por supuesta
corrupción y aquí es donde llega el
auténtico momento de la verdad para
ucrania ese gran momento del que
hablábamos al principio del vídeo y en
ese tal igor kolomoisky es nada más y
nada menos que el dueño de la televisión
donde felinski se hizo famoso no solo
eso es uno de los principales apoyos del
actual presidente de ucrania tanto que
incluso ha sido su jefe de gabinete
durante sus primeros años de presidencia
en otras palabras que hasta el azote de
la corrupción en ucrania ha necesitado a
un oligarca para darse a conocer y
diréis de que se le acusa al bueno de
colon whisky pues veréis además de tener
una televisión colomo es que era el
dueño de un banco él privatbank este
banco es responsable de un fraude que ha
costado las arcas del estado más de
cinco mil quinientos millones de dólares
vamos ya hablamos de corrupción pero
corrupción a gran escala y este es el
auténtico momento de la verdad para
volodymyr selenski no sería la primera
ni la segunda vez que un oligarca
ucraniano sale libre de cargos de un
juicio gracias a sus conexiones
políticas
ah
dicho de otra forma que ahora mismo
ucrania está viviendo un auténtico
dilema y el resultado de este dilema es
clave para el futuro del país así que
ahora la pregunta es para vosotros será
distinto esta vez permitirá hacer en
esquí que juzguen a su amigo de verdad
ucrania está lista para acabar con sus
élites de oligarcas y acabar con la
corrupción es posible que veamos en unos
años como ucrania deja de ser pobre
podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios y como siempre no olvidéis
que sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las
semanas así que suscribiros al visual
político y dadle a la campanita para no
perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones si os ha gustado este
vídeo dadle a like y nos vemos en el
próximo un abrazo y hasta pronto
[Música]